they were really close I think we're
just you know just a little more
consistent performance away from
consistently playing with these guys but
you know we've got them at home their
place twice
I've said this before you know we got to
get one of these at home it's a
different ballgame it's different you
know playing in 20 20 degree weather and
snow cold and wind is a different type
of game that playing here Aaron Rodgers
after 37 to 20 lost last night to the
San Francisco 49ers they came within
just a couple of inches of being in
position to host the NFC Championship
back to that week 17 game Jacob
Hollister can't get the ball to the goal
line if he does Packers were the one
seat Chris it was a remarkable year for
the Packers to go 13 and 3 they never
felt like a dominant team but their
record reflected dominance they just
found a way Aaron Rodgers said that last
night this wasn't one of the most
talented teams and he went on and on in
that kind of subtle way where he doesn't
call anyone out who used to be there but
by the praise he heaps on the guys who
were there and he says this year will
always be special to me because it
became fun again says something about
what they'd been through the past few
years and he thinks things are moving in
the right direction I don't know that I
agree with that I think they got a lot
of work to do to catch the 49ers well
yeah to catch the 49ers you're right I
am you know but what's a lot of work to
do you know again the NFL the offseason
you know they get you know another
interior defensive lineman maybe a
difference maker there another
linebacker you know they got to get a
difference-maker on the offensive side
of the ball can't just always be Rogers
and Davante Adams right and then they're
gonna continue to grow within these new
systems they're both in I mean
offensively and defensively but
especially offensively with Matt Lafleur
he'll continue to grow in that offense
add more to will to become dangerous
there as well this is still a really
good team you know Bo hey we had all
these questions you know going into the
playoffs going into late in the season
we wondered you know we said this is one
of the more underwhelming number two
seeds we've seen you started off the
segment with not a lot of dom
wins a dominant record but really you
know they just played the right way a
lot of the times had a fairly easy
schedule Rodgers didn't make mistakes
he's good enough to make a play here or
there still to get them over the edge
and that's there it was but they don't
have the talent the 49ers have right
Mike and I'm I don't know you tell me
where do you think they start as far as
a player or a position that they need to
improve on their football team it's the
trenches yeah question you got to get a
better offensive line and a better
defensive line that's how you slow down
that run and that's how you give aaron
rodgers more time so he doesn't have to
worry about the guys from that san
francisco front for chasing him around
all over the place i mean look at the
first half drives for the packers three
punts bumbled snap which was just kind
of a weird thing that you don't see em
that was here yeah that was huge
interception and then another punt and
it's 27 nothing at halftime it was worse
than last time around last time it was
23 and he didn't think it getting any
worse
this time is 27 nothing at intermission
they never had anything a part of the
game plan that really slowed the Green
Bay Packer I mean the San Francisco
49ers down the 49ers just were able to
attack they looked like they felt very
comfortable you know Green Bay's offense
it has been yes a little bit predicated
on their run success a lot like the
Vikings to then be able to go to the
play-action pass game where Rodgers is
dangerous the run game never got going
so therefore the play-action pass game
really didn't have the effect on the
49ers defense but you know you're right
Mike I mean they're just overwhelmed by
the size and physicality of the San
Francisco 49ers that's where they got to
get bigger and better I also think they
needed another weapon on the offensive
side of the ball around Aaron Rodgers
too you know there's just nobody that
scares you or backs you off in Green Bay
yes there's Davante Adams the Davante
Adams is not the kind of guy again
that's gonna catch a slant route and run
for 70 yards he's not that kind of guy
he's great in the middle of the field
he's great route runner yes he can beat
you deep but he doesn't strike fear of
God into a defender they need another
guy on the other side of the ball a
little bit to be that type of guy to
back people off from the run game to
make thing people think twice about
blitzing them you know those are the
things that will help them so they're
close but they need a few
players I think on both sides of the
ball and they never really could get
into a rhythm offensive no and I was a
big proponent when we talked about it
last week they needed to keep aaron
rodgers on the move they never went up
tempo they never gotten a chance where
they could have maybe they should have
come out of the gates I mean in
hindsight anything they would have done
differently than what they did yesterday
they should have tried to do because we
know what happened yesterday just
flat-out didn't work but it just never
felt like anything could get going and
Chris I'm very big on studying the
demeanor and the you know body language
and the facial expressions of guys
during these games I'm amazed that they
even made it interesting in the second
half semi interesting yeah why
interesting because let me tell you what
I sensed at the end of the first half
was a group of guys that just wanted to
get the hell out of there well they they
you're I mean yeah they were looking at
this going man what have we got to do to
beat this team they're just they're on
another love they were shell-shocked I
think you know that's why the the start
of the game was important for them to
get some sort of confidence going to go
okay this isn't gonna be like last time
we got something here we can make
something happen
no they couldn't they couldn't back with
the 49ers off the 49ers on offense just
kept coming downhill just applying the
pressure in the run game and on the
defensive side of the ball they could
never back the 49ers off either I mean
yeah the run game didn't get going in
the first half you know Rodgers his
completion percentage was good but it
was for very little yards so there was
nothing downfield backing that 49ers
team off that way the 49ers were just in
full-fledged
attack mode the whole time and really
never had to come out of the position of
power really from the get-go of the game
yeah and God how demoralizing it has to
be when you have a great season when
you're one game away from the Superbowl
and it just all crashes down like that
and even though Aaron Rodgers what he
said sounded optimistic surprisingly
optimistic after the game he he was
standing it like he was shell-shocked to
how could you not be after going through
something like when your season comes
down to it and and it just should the
fact that he was able to fashion
anything remotely confident it just
shows you how important confidence to
the point of delusion is for
professional athletes they need to think
they always have a chance
Duffy even after they've had the crap
kicked out of them yeah
he's a cat he's that they're not gonna
give up in Green Bay they're just gonna
look at it and go eh a play here a play
there we get a player on the offensive
side a player in the defensive side we
can be right back in this game with
better results
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports